[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i have
the pleasure of talking
with zubi who is a rapper and author and
the host of
real talk with zubi welcome to the dark
horse podcast
thank you brett happy to be here so um
where on earth are you located at the
moment
so i am based in the south coast of
england southampton to be
specific this is where i live so uh yeah
just
chilling here you're just chilling down
there on the south coast of england
yeah now um i think probably
before we get into substance we need to
talk a little bit about
your trajectory so your
accent does not sound british i know
from wikipedia that at least they claim
you grew up in saudi arabia is that
right
oh cool i have a wikipedia page now i'll
need to make sure it's accurate
uh yeah so i was born in england i grew
up in saudi arabia
when i was there i went to an american
school
up until fifth grade and then after that
so at 11 years old i actually went to
boarding school
so i went to the boarding school in the
uk from the age of 11
and was in school for seven years over
here while still living in saudi arabia
going back and forth between the two
countries
then i did really well in school i got
into oxford university i studied
computer science there
that's also when i first started making
music and put out my first album
and um so i've been living in the uk
permanently for
about 12 years but i've been here on and
off for more than 20 years so that's why
the accent is
it confuses everybody whether i'm
talking to british people or americans
or
whatever everyone always gets confused
about where i'm from
so how did you end up in saudi arabia um
so my dad is a medical doctor and when i
was a baby
um my family was primarily living in
nigeria at the time
but um i don't remember any of this but
i've just been told the story
but he got he got the a great job
opportunity to go and work out in saudi
arabia
and um he took it and within a few days
the whole family moved moved out to
saudi um i'm i'm one of five kids i've
got
four four brothers and sisters so um
apparently this was a little bit of a
shock to the system but i was just a
baby at the time so
i have no recollection of it whatsoever
so that's how we ended up there
well that has certainly given you a
perspective that most of us will not
have
and i'm definitely going to ask you
about that
but you also say south coast of england
is uh do a lot of computers wash up on
the south coast of england that need
some computer scientists to navigate
them
uh no i mean in terms of my my actual
degree to be honest i
i don't really use it very much in my in
my day-to-day life these days
i never really did i mean after i
graduated i did my music full-time for
one year
and then um before i graduated i had um
i
had a job opportunity on the table to go
and work for
a big management consulting company in
london but um
i differ i accepted the offer but i
deferred it for a year because i wanted
to release a second album
and i wanted to travel around and do
some stuff with my music and then
eventually i moved to london
i actually worked in the corporate world
for three years as a consultant which is
a part of the story that
not a lot of people know and then in
2011
late 2011 i made the big decision
after getting a promotion at work i was
like all right i want to go and
pursue my music full-time so i've been
self-employed since november 2011 so
coming up to nine years now
and um since then i've put out a lot
more music i mean i've released five
albums and
three eps in total now and its stuff has
evolved beyond the music
in 2018 2019 i just started getting more
involved in
some aspects of the of the cultural
conversation and social commentary and
stuff like that
of course early last year i um i started
my podcast and then i
had a video this is the deadlift video
which went super
hyper viral and led a lot of people to
discover me and led to appearances on a
lot of the biggest podcasts and stuff in
the world
so that was a sort of catalyst moment
where
a lot of people all over the world
suddenly discovered me
and then because of all the work i'd
been putting in over the past decade
plus
i think a lot of people stuck around
because they saw okay this wasn't just
one
random viral tweet this guy's actually
interesting he's doing this he's doing
that he's got some interesting views
he's a smart guy etc
so i was able to sort of turn that flash
point into
something beyond just a little internet
moment
so do you still hold the women's
deadlift record
uh yeah i mean unless something really
changes i think i've probably got that
for a while
unless another no unless some other dude
figures it out
unless someone else works out my hack
yeah yeah um i mean let's just put it
this way
uh how much did you lift it was 528
pounds something it was something like
that yeah it was
it was well below my maximum but that
was actually part of the fun like my
best is
606 so that was that video was actually
just from one of my training sessions
it wasn't like uh you know it wasn't a
max effort lift or anything i just had
it on my phone
and um the way that came about was i
just kept seeing these stories
popping up on my timeline and seeing
things in the news and whatever and
out of curiosity i just thought you know
i'm really good at dead lifting i wonder
what the british women's deadlift record
is
so i just googled it and i've already
had that video on my phone i was like oh
this video already
is more than the record so i just so i
just posted it up there just thinking
okay this is um
you know if as anyone who uses twitter a
lot right you put things out there you
don't really
think about them a lot of people think i
sort of sat down and
worked out this whole marketing strategy
and i was like no i just put it out
there like
any of my other tweets and very quickly
i realized that something that something
was going on and
it was resonating on a whole different
level and it just started spreading like
wildfire i think
it hit 10 000 views within a matter of
minutes
hit a hundred thousand views in a couple
of hours and then i woke up in the
morning it was over half a million
and it just kept going and going and
growing and growing and
started getting contacted by various
media outlets
in the uk in the u.s et cetera a couple
weeks later
i wake up in the morning and um my phone
is just going crazy
and i've just got people on on in my dms
and in my whatsapp and everything yo
joe rogan just mentioned you want to
show joe rogan i was like wait what like
and i saw the episode and so it just
snowballed it just grew and grew and
grew
and um yeah i'm still here sort of 18
months later trying to
trying to catch up on things and and
work out what i'm doing in the world
well i was not aware of you until that
and the
instant i saw it and i mean instant i
saw it i thought
this is beautiful and then
let's just cards on the table here when
i saw what you had done
i thought this is really sweet but i bet
the guy's a dick
i looked at how you did it and it was so
compassionate and decent that i thought
oh
man this uh this really resonates and
um so first off let me just say i admire
the way you made the point without um
twisting the knife thank you thank you
it was really
it was really well done and and i i also
appreciate that you
you did it not only with compassion but
with a sense of humor
yeah and uh you know not a mean-spirited
one so anyway i think you
you really advanced the conversation
because suddenly we were able to talk
about the absurdity
of trans women competing in women's
athletics yeah i mean i think it's worth
saying as well is that
i firstly i have quite a lot of trans
followers like once once you get once
your audience grows to a certain level
you know you have people across the
board and all types of diversity in
every sense of it
and the vast majority of them thought it
was hilarious
right like the messages i got from
actual from people who are actually
trans were like
dude that's hilarious because i think
like with many things
the activists are not representative
of the people they claim to be
advocating for
and like you said there was no there was
no malice in it there was no
anger there was no all right i wanna you
know attack people or whatever it's just
like
this is silly so i'm just gonna take
this logic
and instead of arguing against it i'm
just gonna say
okay if those are the rules here let's
go
and i think it's sort of i think it was
a bit of a checkmate maneuver in a lot
of ways because people either need to
accept that i am the british women's
deadlift record holder
or they have to say okay that's not
maybe we need to think about the whole
uh anyone who says they're a woman
is a woman thing and should be allowed
to compete in sport etc
you know no matter how progressive
someone wants to be or how liberal
someone is
there are still things that it's like
okay that's a
bad idea for a lot of reasons and i
think that's really why it resonated
yeah it's a terrible idea at the level
of sport and it's a tragic idea at the
point we get to things like
prisons right yeah i mean you can't very
well have a man declare himself a woman
in order to go to a woman's prison
you know so we we have to draw a line
somewhere and for me
and um when i was teaching at evergreen
heather and i had many trans students it
was actually not uncommon and we got
along with them
very well and we treated them
compassionately
and then encountering trans activism
after
we were driven out of evergreen it's
like you say there's a dichotomy between
the activists and the people who are in
the community
for other reasons so it's something
people need to be aware of because there
is this
there's such a focus on the trans
activist that it seems like they speak
for the whole community but
that's not the case yeah i think they're
doing a massive disservice to be to be
totally honest because
let's be real i mean evergreen is a is a
unique place but most people don't know
anybody who's trans
most people have never actually met a
transgender person i only have because
i'm in the public with my music and i'm
connected to so many people so
even if it's very small percent of the
population okay cool like i've i've
still met
you know maybe a dozen or so and
and out of those people you know people
have generally been cool and nice and
friendly and you know they're not trying
to
impose anything on on anybody so
i think it's uh it's actually quite a
big problem because
like you said what most people will see
and how most people will judge things
is based off of the people who are who
have the loudest voice
and who are making all of these demands
and trying to force
people to use certain words and trying
to bully people and harass people and
come into sports and do this and do that
and it makes a lot of people think like
you know for someone who doesn't think
with a lot of nuance
it's easy to forgive someone for
thinking oh my gosh like
all of these people are crazy because
every time i hear something about
this whole issue it's it's something
totally
totally bonkers and i know that's not
the case
but yeah i think oftentimes with these
activists they just end up doing
more harm than good just like i think is
happening in a lot of other things when
you're seeing what's going on
now with you know this whole inverted
commas anti-racism movement
which has become very racist in many in
many aspects
and it just to me to me it's just it's
actually regressive
right people like to say that someone
like myself who's more you know
conservative leaning on many things
people
like to say that i'm the one being
regressive but i'm like look at what
you're doing here and here right i'm
the last week i spent two days just
getting attacked
for the fact that i said that it's bad
to be racist to white people
right like i was i was getting emails
dms mess like all kinds of horrible
stuff for me
saying no this is bad right like
right this isn't good i don't think we
should judge people based on the color
of their skin or call people
inferior or do any of this and then i
start getting attacked i'm just like
what kind of what is this world that
we're
that we're living in that that is
considered
uh some i don't know it's it's um it's a
strange thing
it's a strange thing i mean it's beyond
strange i think those of us
who uh without any ability to defend it
i will just say those of us who get it
i think are having this constant
experience of
i can't believe we're having this
conversation
yeah it's weird but you know i have a
theory about this and this is something
i've sort of observed over the years and
this is that
i think any sort of social justice
movement let's call it that that doesn't
have a clearly defined finish line
ends up becoming what it's set to fight
against
and i think that we we're seeing this i
think we're living in an age of over
correction
where it's like okay we were things were
kind of at a happy balance in a medium
and that whoa it just sort of swung that
way
and it went from it went from
you know if you go back decades it went
from okay it's acceptable to judge
people based on
the color of their skin to
no that's not acceptable and we
shouldn't do that to
no now we must judge people based on the
color of their skin in the name of
anti-racism and it's
and with that you've got all this sort
of anti-white rhetoric and sometimes
anti-jewish rhetoric and
people trying to roll back
discrimination laws so that you can hire
based on and you're just like wait what
is going on
or if i look at certain aspects of what
people call modern day feminism
which you know i have i have my own my
own issues with
but again it went from a movement that
was like okay
women should have equal rights to men
and be allowed to vote you know inherit
property etc
yeah i'm on board and then it went to
okay cool we've kind of got
a happy balance you know at least in the
west not not everywhere in the world but
cool we've we've kind of got this the
rules are fair the laws are equal
and then it sort of evolved into men are
evil and
kill all kill all men and and you're
just like
and then you've got like the trans thing
that comes into it as well which
actually affects women more than it
affects men
whether you're talking like changing
rooms or prisons or the sports thing or
whatever
and it just becomes confusing you're
just like wait what's
what's what's going on here and it's
strange because it's all called progress
but
i'm not i'm not convinced that it is
oh i agree it is the um so the way i've
been saying it is that
there there is this idea in progressive
circles
about correcting the wrongs but it's
actually divided into two camps
there are those of us who want to end
oppression permanently
and there are those who want to turn the
tables of oppression
and that turn the tables thing results
in the uninvention
of so many achievements and i'm not
claiming
at least in the u.s i'm not claiming
that we ever got to the goal
right but we knew what it was right we
knew
what what we were trying to achieve and
now we have
um begun attacking that very set of
objectives
in order to justify this uh
this vindictive um
movement and i mean that you can say a
lot of things about it but one thing i
think we can say
with certainty is that from a systems
perspective
this doesn't lead anywhere there's no
there's no stable system you could
define
that would uh match the objectives of
the movement we see
tearing apart the us at the moment if
you were to institute their
their proposals you would end up with
warlordism and basically a permanent
state of lineages fighting against each
other which
if there's one great achievement of the
west it's that we
we spotted that we needed to escape that
and we we were
indeed headed there so yeah what what a
tragedy
yeah it's weird it's like in many ways
things are better than they've
ever been but people insist that they're
worse
than they've ever been or that they
haven't gotten better you'll hear people
saying things like
oh racism is just as bad as it was 50
years ago but
it's just different and i'm like don't
say that you know
right it's like no that's not that's not
a helpful statement and like you said
this sort of
people wanting revenge rather than
equality
is is a big problem and from from a sort
of psychological perspective
i can understand how someone gets into
that mind state
but it's it's not constructive it's not
helpful
and it does move things it does move
things backwards because i think
most decent people across like you know
whether someone is left leaning right
leaning centrist you know apolitical
whatever
i think when it comes to the sort of
core
ideas of you know around equality and
fairness in in the sort of true sense
as much as that is achievable i think
most people are
pretty much on board most people i'm not
seeing a lot of people
who are pro-racism or pro-sexism or
pro-you know
pro-transphobia or or any kind of phobia
or ism
and i think that we also fail to
recognize
just how much progress has been made
very quickly
and it's odd that people don't want to
people don't want to recognize that we
live in a very pessimistic it's a very
pessimistic mindset
and a lot of people are just very very
pessimistic and
it's weird to me and i think a lot of
this also perhaps my perspective on it
also stems from my background right so
my family background is originally from
nigeria i've been to nigeria many times
like i said i lived in saudi arabia for
19 years
so i've seen different cultures and
places and nations and so
my sort of viewpoint for example if
someone is calling
england a patriarchy right as someone
who grew up in saudi arabia i'm like
wait what do you what are you even what
are you talking about like what are you
comparing this
what are you comparing this to right if
someone is saying oh
america is the most racist country in
the world i'm like where have you
where else have you been you know like
there are
if you go to certain countries in africa
including nigeria
or you go to certain asian countries or
south american countries etc
you there is greater conflict between
ethnic groups
and tribes within that same country than
there is
across like you know black and white
americans or black and white british
people or whatever
like and it and it by miles i mean look
at if you want to look at extreme cases
you know look at things like the rwandan
genocide which happened in my own
in my own lifetime look at some of the
stuff that's going on in nigeria right
if you're
a christian from the south it's not
particularly safe to go up north into
the muslim territories etc
because you've got you've got boko haram
you have like you know terrorist groups
you've got the
and also just in terms of i don't know
say you wanted to marry someone wanted
to marry someone from
a different tribe or want it and this is
all within the same country this is
people who to an outsider
all look the same so when people here in
the west are sort of
creating this picture that you know i
just step outside as a black man and oh
my gosh
like i'm just being oppressed and
attacked and whatever i'm kind of like
this reality that people are conjuring
up is just
not it doesn't reflect real life and
this is not to say that
everything is perfect it's not to say
that none of these
isms or phobias exist to some degree
but generally as a society in 2020 i'm
like man
it's pretty darn good right it's so good
that we're looking for stuff
that you know we're almost people almost
inventing
things to be outraged by in the past few
weeks we've seen so many
things that are being done whether this
is uh changing who voices the
does the voices of cartoon characters or
uh changing
changing the labels on food or going
back and trying to revise
uh comedy or tv shows etc and i'm like
no no one no one demanded this no no one
was really
i i'm not aware of any black person who
was offended by aunt jemima and uncle
ben
i don't know who made this decision
everyone everyone was cool with it
so yeah it's a it's a it's a strange
phenomenon i think we're living in a bit
of a
moral panic and like i said before an
overcorrection
i think people uh who have not had the
opportunity to travel
really it's very hard to talk across
that boundary because if you have seen
it elsewhere
then the preposterousness of the claims
is transparent and it feels like it
should be easy to convey but
but it's really it's really not now
i agree with you wholeheartedly even
here in the u.s
there is vast agreement on the idea that
racism is bad
and that we don't want a society that
has those biases built in
where conservatives and and progressives
tend to disagree
is how close to that objective we are
sure so
but but that's that's a very different
disagreement than a question of whether
or not
there's real racism lurking in the minds
of
most whites or even every white as
as the mythology would have it and it's
such a
an incorrect diagnosis that it's almost
hard to imagine how we get back from it
right yeah
yeah yeah sorry go ahead go ahead there
you go yeah no i was gonna say i think
um
like i said it's just um so much of this
stems in pessimism
it really it's really really just such a
pessimistic
you know i know it's called critical
theory um it's just such a pessimistic
negative view of humanity and
individuals and people right the idea
that
you know i've met so many i've literally
met hundreds of thousands of people
at this point and in different countries
you know in 30 something different
countries and you learn like you know
most people are decent
most people want to get on with life you
want to have a career be happy
find romance have a family you know
that's generally what people are about
they're not trying to run around
you know harming or or hurting each
other if if that were the case then
cities cities in general would just be a
nightmare right you wouldn't
you wouldn't be able to have cities like
london and new york where you've just
got
so much diversity across the whole board
you know people would just be
maiming each other constantly and it's
like that's not
that's not the case and so and i think
also the
the hysteria it turns
away it turns away people who otherwise
could be
allied in many ways i don't really like
the term ally because it's been
it's been sort of ruined but um yeah it
turns away people who could be allies so
when people say all white people are
racist
right or when someone says you know
all you know and this is something i
have to be careful with sometimes myself
because
you know i'm i'm no fan of sort of you
know wokism and
a lot of the social justice stuff but i
myself have to be careful sometimes to
try not to paint with too
broad a brush on that side just like i
don't want someone to say like
oh all conservatives are x or all
libertarians or y
or all these people or whatever but um
i think one of the um i think one of the
issues there is i think that
on the on the left side of the spectrum
i don't think people
i think you do this very well and this
is something i really admire you for
is that i think on that side of the
spectrum people are less willing to rate
to acknowledge
and reign in the crazies right like i
think most most
it's very hard to find like a
conservative who is
defensive of the real alt-right
or who is defensive of actual you know
neo-nazis or white supremacists or you
know ex
legitimate far-right people right it's
like no this is the line
and we're no nobody was nobody was
making excuses for charlottesville right
people pretend that wasn't but nobody
every
everyone was like no this is not bad but
if you look at what's going on with with
antifa
for example even people in positions of
power even mayors
governors that said nobody wants to eat
people on the news no one wants to just
come out and say
this is bad no this is wrong like we
don't we don't want
these people like we don't associate
with them like people don't want to draw
that line
and so i think until that happens i kind
of feel like in this whole
i don't know this culture war as people
call it i actually feel like
what's sort of needed in a way is more
like
good and courageous and principled
liberals
to sort of speak up and be willing to
draw that line and say
okay look this this is going this is
going too far here
rather than just sort of staying quiet
or sort of tacitly approving of it
just like i would think you know if on
the right side of the spectrum if
stuff really did start going far
i think you know i know i myself but a
lot of people would be happy to be like
okay look like
no this is not this is not the way
forward right this type of rhetoric this
type of action etc
you know if i mean i don't know imagine
if a group of
you know right-wing trump supporters
created their own autonomous zone
in a city and start and started you know
running it you
the reaction would be really different
right nobody would the mayor wouldn't
come out and say oh yeah it's like
it's like a block party and everyone's
just having fun people would be like oh
my gosh this is
this is a fascist takeover like this is
uh
you know it would be the media response
would be different everything would be
totally different
but somehow that can happen or people
can be looting buildings and setting
places on fire running around in masks
beating people up
and no one wants to just say this is
wrong
and until people can do that i think
we might just this issue might just keep
getting worse
the cowardice on the part of
people on the left to call out what is
wrong
is staggering yeah i i cannot believe it
and you're exactly right i love your
example
yes if if far right wingers
declared an autonomous zone i mean that
would just be
it'd be the end of history would come to
a halt and we would all be confronting
the autonomous zone together but
somehow coming from the left it can't be
and did you say that see they were doing
racial segregation there too
did he say oh of course they were doing
racism
i mean this is the thing when this came
to evergreen
i had my wait what what are you
suggesting
moment and then you know to the extent
that people
stopped rationalizing that it wasn't
happening happening they thought okay
it's just evergreen
and then you know three years later it
has now spilled out into
you know the whole of the us and it's
also spilled into
europe weirdly which has a very
different racial dynamic
at least in my opinion i'm actually it's
one of the things i want to ask you
about
but my sense is
having done a fair amount of traveling
in europe
the even the black white dynamic is
different than we have here in the u.s
have you spent much time in the u.s um a
decent amount of time i was there for
three months last year
i went to ten different cities and i've
been there a few about six times in
total
okay so you've got recent experience do
you also have the sense when you cross
the pond
that you are engaging a very different
interracial dynamic
um for me personally in my own sort of
personal experience
um in the uk in the u.s i had a i had a
great time there and there was no
no issues in that regard um
one thing i do certainly observe though
based on people i've known over the
years and this goes to you know when i
lived in saudi arabia even
you know there were lots of american
families living there you know white
american families black american
families asian american etc
and so there i always noticed even from
a relatively young age that there was a
difference in the mindset and the way
that people would talk about
you know any type of racial issue and
how people would sort of view things
and i see it i see it online right i
spend a lot of time on social media
i talk to a lot of people and the
mentality
is certain difference is certainly
different and even the terminology is
different i think it's very interesting
that
in the in the usa you know you guys say
black american african-american latino
american
white american etc here we just say
british
right there you go so it's not common to
hear that
this person is white british or this
person is a black brit
you know like sometimes sometimes you'll
hear it but it's quite uncommon
regardless of someone's ethnic origin
people just say british and i think that
in america
you know this might seem like a small
thing but i think that it's quite a good
example of just the
the different type of thinking or even
when it comes to politics you hear terms
like
the black vote right the white vote the
it's sort of people are more grouped
into blocks in the uk
yeah sure there are certain trends and
patterns in the voting
but you wouldn't hear politicians or
people in the media or etc talk about
like
the black vote in the uk or
and i understand there are historical
reasons for that there are demographic
reasons for that you know
black people are much smaller pop uh
percentage of the population here in the
uk etc
but i think from a from a unity
perspective
and from the idea of moving away from
various forms of identitarianism i feel
like
as long as people speak in these terms
then it's likely to sort of keep people
thinking that way because it does make
people think like okay
you know there's black americans and
there's white americans and you know
it's
by using those labels i think it sort of
keeps people
locked in that way of thinking and i
think there are i think there are a lot
of people who want to be
who want to be locked in that way of
thinking but i think that there are also
a lot of people who don't and just feel
like you know
we're over this you know we have eyes we
can see what people look like
that's cool that's interesting but it's
not the ultimate defining
characteristic of a person
so i think some of it goes back to what
you were saying about pessimism
and i must say the tenor of the
conversation has changed
radically in the last decade and one of
the things
that i suspect is behind the uh
the change is that there's almost a loss
of confidence that true equality
can be achieved which i think is
absolutely tragic because
i i i effectively know that it can be
right having traveled having spent a lot
of time with students of different
backgrounds
i don't believe there's any barrier to
it but
people seem to have responded to um
a kind of evidence that i don't think
they know how to interpret because
frankly it it requires an understanding
of human biology
that almost nobody has so i was just
talking to coleman hughes about this
actually
that i think people are drawing a false
conclusion from what they see in sport
right we have
very different uh capacity to engage in
different sports
based on race or what we would call race
based on population of origin and
it's hard-coded right there's a reason
that ethiopians and kenyans dominate
marathon running
for example right and so i think there's
an expectation
that that has an implication for
cognitive stuff that it
doesn't have because human cognition
functions on a whole different basis
it's basically software
and i wonder if
the move to effectively
hard code some kind of positive racism
into this into the very fabric of
society is a response
to a private belief that nothing else
will work
and you know i feel like one of the lone
voices just shouting don't do
that because actually you can achieve
real equality and it does look like a
country in which you don't refer to
somebody as a black brit you refer to
them as a brit
right yeah we can get there but it
requires that we address the software
layer carefully and properly which we
haven't done
i think it's also tricky because people
have different definitions
of many words including equality of
course including
racism including fairness including all
of these terms that we use you know
diversity
when someone says diversity to me that
doesn't just mean having a bunch of
people who
have different skin colors and perhaps
different sexualities and genders
but who are all in lockstep on thinking
when i think of diversity i think of it
in
across the board i think of
ideologically the way people think
people's ideas
you know people's character etc that's
you know
it's it's a whole picture when i think
of equality i think very much of
equality of opportunity and i even
recognize that
equality of opportunity is also
not totally achievable right i think you
can have equality under the law
equality and policy equality
in the system as much as you can but
as we've as you've already alluded to
you're still going to get very disparate
outcomes because not everything can be
controlled and there are millions of
millions of factors
that make us all different you can see
this even just within a family right
you've got the same parents
you've raised in the same household in
the same place etc
and all of the children go off and do
totally different things they have
different interests different
personalities
their earnings might be massively
different from each other all of these
things are just totally different so
to expect that any kind of equality of
outcome across like a group or a whole
population to me is just sort of crazy
and i think that
equality of outcome as we sort of know
this already through history it's a very
dangerous idea
and it's also an idea that it's it's
unachievable
and the only way you could achieve it is
just by like raising everybody down
right because right there's there's no
you know you people have different
intellectual capability people have
different interests etc
so and people do this in in lots of
weird places um
i mean even if you look at something
like the push
for gender equity gender parity
you know 50 50 across the board and lots
of different things
um that firstly it's funny because they
only ever push for that
in certain types of jobs and in other
ones they're totally happy for men to do
100 of it
but also it's just it it totally denies
as you said biological reality it denies
people's freedom of choice
it denies the fact that men and women
are different and people have different
interests etc
i mean i i see this myself because i'm
in the world of music
and over here in the uk for example
there are
there are certain schemes in place in
the uk music industry to try to make
um the majority of uk festivals music
festivals
to have 50 50 gender split on the lineup
okay i'm a rapper right my
genre of music there are 20 there are 30
male rappers
for every female rapper and that's not
because women are not
allowed to rap right it's just that
that's that's how it is it turns out
that males are more interested
in rapping and that's okay to me i'm
like okay as long as women are
allowed to rap and they're not being
discriminated against and treated
unfairly etc
then to me i'm like okay that's the best
you can do right that's the best you can
do
we can't start forcing we don't want to
start discriminating against the men and
and this does happen i mean
there was a music festival i wanted to
apply to and
essentially on the form it basically
said that if you're a male
you're probably not going to get it
because they're trying to get gender
parodies so it's like oh interesting so
you know i now can't get this
opportunity because
i'm male isn't that sexism and um
yeah i don't know it just seems like a
lot of people don't don't think
these things through very well so it's
sort of it sounds good on the tin just
to say we want 50 50
gender equality on the lineup right and
people cheer and everyone's like yeah
but very few people are going wait hang
on
this first firstly why do you want that
like why is that super important
and then secondly how can you even
achieve this
if you if you've got 90 10 on the inputs
how are you going to get 50 50
on the outputs without some serious
discrimination
going on in the middle and that's the
only way that it can even be done
it is the only way so uh i don't know if
i've talked about this anywhere
during the evergreen meltdown like the
week in which things went
completely haywire my students were
watching this happen and you know the
students who protested were not people i
even knew
not only were they not my students i'd
never met them okay my own students
remained
loyal throughout and this one young
woman in my class
kept uh approaching me and saying you
have to read this
thing and i'm like look there's a lot
going on i don't have time to read it
she's like no
you have to read this is a young black
woman
and at some point she had been so
adamant that it was really important
that i read this right now that i
actually carved out the time and i sat
down it was a story harrison bergeron
by kurt vonnegut have you read it i
haven't read it i've heard of it but i
haven't read it
you got to read it she was absolutely
right and it makes your exact point
which is there is a way to achieve true
equality of outcome and it's by
hobbling everybody who is above the
minimum
right and so it's this dystopian vision
of
a world in which every capacity you have
is interfered with to
make it equal with everybody else and it
is uh
it's a very it makes your point uh
and it is correct so yes quality of
outcome
is not desirable if you attempt to
create it you will
create a dystopian nightmare and
equality of opportunity isn't exactly
achievable either as you point out
but what you can do the thing that i
would advocate
is that we would we should want to get
as close to a situation where
bad luck is randomly distributed with
respect to things like
race and sex right so the other
point is we can't guarantee that you're
going to be equally
capable or have equal access but what we
don't want to be able to do is say look
if you're black in the u.s we know
you're not going to be able to access
the market nearly as effectively as this
other population
because that's not luck right yeah bad
luck that's not randomly distributed
isn't luck it's something else
and we have a lot of that mostly it
doesn't have anything to do with modern
racism
it has to do with the echoes of past
racism and a system that simply
perpetuates current patterns of
distribution into the future and
amplifies them
so in some sense i think this is the
explanation for what we're seeing
is there's a there's a correct sense
that things
are not functional and that
they are in they are rigged and that the
way they are rigged is not evenly some
populations suffer more from the way the
system is rigged than others
but the diagnosis of how the rigging
works and what it's based in and what
the remedies are
is pure nonsense yeah what do you think
are are some of the remedies to that
point that could be done
without making things worse or without
sort of
heavy discrimination against
other people because at the moment in
terms of the
proposed solutions that seems to be
primarily
what i see like i can understand
especially in especially in the usa
right i don't think anyone again i don't
think anyone disagrees
that you know the there's there are some
aftershock effects
from the legacy of things like slavery
jim crow
you know redlining certain welfare
policies etc
i think that that is you know how how
much of that what percentage of that is
the problem
i think a lot of people would disagree
on but
i think most people you know will will
recognize that but i
guess the question is what can be done
now
to rectify that without just
you know stamping on everybody else or
actually
instituting prejudiced or discriminatory
policies what do you think well
unfortunately the answer
is upstream of all of the consequences
that people can see
so i do think we more or less know where
the problem is and what to do about it
but the answer doesn't it sounds like a
dodge
okay so what i would argue is that
you've got a cascade of consequences
that
come from what i would call opportunity
hoarding
that in the u.s in particular but really
throughout the west there is a process
that allows people who have gained
wealth and therefore political power
those two things shouldn't be synonymous
but they turn out to be
once you have that kind of power it is
inevitable
that um you will get the evolution of
strategies to prevent competitors from
rising up and
uh displacing you so this is
the bad side of conservatism and i
believe me i recognize that there's a
very positive side to conservatism
in fact i say i want to live in a world
so good that i get to be a conservative
but what happens is mechanisms to block
competitors evolve they're not even
necessarily conscious
but they serve to
to preserve the distribution of of
well-being
and the result of that is
that there is artificial scarcity at the
levels below
so the disparity in wealth that we see
which people find so shocking
isn't really a problem it's a symptom of
a problem
right it's it's a symptom of the fact
that opportunity has been
concentrated in one stratum and
although you can defend a disparity in
wealth i've never heard a good defense
of a disparity in opportunity
it's simply not desirable from the point
of view of any of the things we claim to
be trying
to maximize so if opportunity is not
broadly distributed
there's a question of who will have
access to it and there's effectively
uh a ladder and those of us
in the middle of the ladder find we do
okay
but we're actually in a kind of jeopardy
because there's so many hungry people
on the run just below right so in other
words if you have
a job and it uh you know pays your
mortgage and
gives you a retirement plan and medical
care and all those things
well you may be doing just fine on the
other hand if something
turns around and your relationship with
your employer goes south
you can lose all of those things very
quickly so
the hunger at the bottom as a result of
extreme scarcity
results in a depression of everybody's
wages for example
because you're not in a position to uh
to negotiate for more if there are many
people who could take your job and
would willingly do so and at the very
bottom of the ladder
what you have is no opportunity
whatsoever now that's no guarantee of
who will be there
but to the extent that opportunity is
let's say
racially not evenly distributed you get
a population that
experiences extremely high unemployment
which of course is going to have a
direct
relationship with the tendency toward
criminality because
nobody wants to go to prison but if you
don't have legitimate opportunities you
will consider
things that put you at higher risk
and then you get into the really
interesting downstream effects
so let's say in the black community
you have a very high rate of
incarceration of men
as a result of criminality that i would
claim has some relationship
to a lack of opportunity once you take
men off the table you create a problem
for women
in mating and dating because their
bargaining position
is eroded because men are in such high
demand
and men who are in high sexual demand
are hard to pin down
for a monogamous relationship so that
results in a lot of
single mothers which results in a lot of
kids who don't have dads and therefore
don't have
a role a male role model which results
in a
breakdown in culture so that's a vicious
cycle
but it's rooted in essentially
political corruption of various kinds
that concentrates
opportunity so i would say if you're
dealing with anything downstream of that
first
you're dealing with a symptom which
doesn't mean you don't have a remedy but
probably it's not going to be a very
good remedy if you don't deal with the
top level
problem and so that's one thing
second thing is
you may have had a very different
experience in school than i did
but um i i did not do well in school
ever
and um when i ended up teaching i ended
up having to teach in a way
that was very different from what normal
teaching would look like because
even just morally speaking i couldn't
live with myself
holding students to standards that i
couldn't have met
right so i had to teach in a different
way this has resulted in
my understanding that the whole school
system
is not really conducive to
generating high quality thinkers it has
a different purpose
so the reason i mention it is
one of the things that we have to remedy
is the way we deliver
school the way we deliver the stuff that
enhances the the mind's ability to think
but if you say well let's just equalize
the schools
in the bad neighborhoods to the ones in
the good neighborhoods you've already
failed because the ones in the good
neighborhoods aren't great either
right they're they're better at getting
you to succeed in society but they're
not really
great at creating high quality thinking
yeah
so uh that's a very long-winded answer
but
basically i would say the problems are
actually upstream
and addressing them is a paramount
concern and really what we should seek
to do is generate
the kinds of developmental environments
that tend to neutralize the uh
bad luck that is so unevenly distributed
yeah yeah i know i i i you know this is
why i just like talking to
intelligent smart people across the
board because this is what is
i think this is what's necessary because
you know conversations like this are
important because
i i feel like seems like the diagnosis
is wrong
right or it's or people are
because of people's political biases and
perhaps political aspirations even
and maybe even just a degree of um
wanting to sort of
wanting to win and wanting to sort of
stick it to the other side
is you get a lot of people who think
they just go all the way on one thing
right so if you're looking at this kind
of issue
there are going to be hundreds of
different factors
that play into something i mean if you
if you're gonna look at two
big sort of spheres you can put these in
of course you have
you have sort of issues in
the system or the environment
and then you have the individual
responsibility and individual behavior
and perhaps cultural elements and i
think that
conservatives tend to very much focus on
the latter including myself right tend
to focus a lot more
on the individual responsibility angle
and you know what's
what's going on in the society and the
culture and people's personal choices
and behavior etc
people more on the left side of the
spectrum tend to focus more on
issues in the system and you know the
the system and policies and things like
that and
the reality is there's always going to
be aspects of both
right like how much weight you put on
one is going to vary from
from person to person but the truth is
and it's like people don't want to admit
this truth
which is that there are things on both
sides
which can be improved so i've spoken to
some people who
they almost they it's like they don't
even believe that human beings have
the capacity to make choices and to like
you know choose their own behavior etc
which is like look i don't
i don't buy that and sometimes i can
find it quite offensive if i've got
someone who's telling me that
sometimes it can almost like suggest
that i've heard i've heard people
talking i i think i know
i know they don't mean it this way but
the way they talk almost suggests that
like almost like black people don't have
like they make an excuse for
all bad behavior to the degree i'm like
what do you not think that people have
agency and can make choices and
you know it's not like it's not clearly
most people aren't behaving in this way
so you can't just like we have to have
standards for people you've got to have
behavioral standards you can't just make
an excuse for every
every bad behavior that someone is
engaging in
and yes i understand that depending on
someone's environment
and their family etc that that's going
to have an
impact on their likelihood to engage in
certain behavior so i'm not here like oh
yeah i want to keep people
stuck in a crap situation like no
that's absolutely not but at the same
time
i think you raise people up by actually
holding people to those equal
standards and not saying oh okay yeah
sure you murdered somebody
but you know your dad wasn't there so
we're going to kind of make and it's
like no no no like we need to raise
everybody up to this
standard and then you know you can do
both at the same time right you can you
can try to
improve all of these things
simultaneously right if there are
like and again even when it comes to you
know people being more conservative like
i don't think there are
there aren't a lot of people who if you
can identify clearly
right like it's not it's not handy when
people sort of scream systemic racism
and scream institutional racism without
telling you
what institution or what structure or
what system
specifically and what should be done
like a lot of people sort of use these
phrases and think it just sort of ends
the argument and i'm kind of like okay
well let's
let's go deep on that like tell me what
what are you talking about because we
can't change history
right we we know history is immutable so
like what can we do now
like what are you proposing and a lot of
people don't really think past that
because
they just want to say systemic racism
and boom they think that's it it's over
and i'm kind of like
no like you got to tell me tell me what
you're talking about because
if you can and if you can point
something out i will
i will agree with you like if it's
factual i'll be like oh okay that's
interesting okay i wasn't
i wasn't aware of that okay what can we
do there
to even it out or to make that more fair
right some people point out for example
um
an example a lot of people use is that i
think this has been maybe done in here
in the uk and in the us i don't know the
numbers and stuff but
there are for example i know there have
been studies so in showing that people
with certain types of names
on applications might you know all other
things being equal they might not
you know they might be less likely to
get a call back after an interview or to
get an interview in the first place
and if that's the case there's a really
simple solution to that like that's not
a
that's not super complicated i'm not i
have no issue like if you want to do
take people's names off i'm like cool do
it like if that
if that makes it more fair do it but
it's also weird because now you're
seeing
i saw just the other day for example
with um i don't know
some orchestra they were saying that
they want to end the blind auditions and
yeah
so this is where i get confused because
i'm like wait
i thought that that was being done to
prevent
that so this is where it just kind of
gets confused
confusing to me because i'm like gosh
like what are people
i thought we were all aiming towards the
same thing but maybe you were
not so i kind of i don't know yeah we we
were aiming toward the same thing yeah
now we're not but yeah look i think the
the deal is relatively simple to state
how we get there is more complicated but
i think this is the deal
a if there's surplus
then there must be enough to go around
in other words if we're really in
surplus and we are
then it should not be the case that
there's a bottom of the ladder that you
have to fall off of that somebody has to
fall off of so we have to make sure
that there is enough and if there is
enough
then we have to make sure that access to
it is not
biased and if there is enough and access
to it is not biased
you have an absolute obligation as an
individual to try
right you have to do your part so this
personal responsibility thing that is so
heavily infused into the conservative
ethos i think is right
but it's not right alone right
in a situation in which there's
artificial scarcity
personal responsibility will decrease
the chances that you fall off the bottom
it's your it's your best bet but it
doesn't mean somebody won't fall off the
bottom
so society has to take care of that part
and then you have to take care of your
part
yeah and if those two things happen
actually we can return
to where we were headed which was yes a
colorblind society
in which it's not going to ever be
perfectly even but
nonetheless we can get to a highly
desirable state
where the degree to which we fall short
of our objectives
is minor yeah we're there
yeah no i think another tricky thing as
well is um you know
what what mechanism is the best thing
to to do that with i mean i'll tell you
like when i when i did go to the states
last year
especially when i was in a when i was in
los angeles in san francisco i'd never
been to those
cities before and i was stunned by some
of the stuff i saw
right so the level the the homelessness
the drug use public drug use
like i had i've been all over the uk
and there is nothing in the uk even
close to that
and i was like whoa this is right i'd
hurt i'd heard things i know this is an
issue in places like you know portland
seattle et cetera but like
i was just seeing things where i was
just like oh my goodness what on earth
is going on and it's even more bizarre
because i realize i'm in one of the
i'm in one of the most expensive cities
in the uk in the sorry in the usa
and the whole world and i also know that
this is
you know if i'm in california this is
most highly taxed state
so in terms of what the
i guess with me part of the reason why i
i lean more libertarian
in many ways is because i'm like man
the government is clearly not interested
in
solving some of the and solving some of
these problems right like because people
have been throwing money at it and
there's clearly
like you know i don't know all of the
ins and outs but
you know there there's the money and it
there's supposedly
i'm just like man like there's a i don't
know i think i almost start to look at
it on a deeper level and just think like
[Music]
as human beings maybe
you know like i don't know if i don't
know if the maybe the government can
solve this but if they can they've had
many many decades
and you know progress has been made in
some areas
but in some things you know it looks
like if i look at the numbers and the
stats it's like ooh that seems to be
getting
worse or you're out there and you're
sort of seeing it with your own eyes
and yeah i don't know it's um it's it's
complicated it's very very
complicated but i think a lot of it also
i think what's necessary and i feel this
i feel this for for all countries but i
think especially for the usa
i think there needs to be a
how would i put it i think people need
to sort of really recognize
their their commonality i think there's
there's so much focus in all these
angles there's so much focus on
differences right whether that's racial
or gender or flipping sexuality
or you know red and blue and this and
that and there's not a lot of like
okay like we're all we're all americans
and look there's gonna be differences
there's gonna be this and that
but we all need to look out for each
other
in certain ways and this is something
that oddly enough
um you know a lot
a lot of people have plenty of
criticisms about somewhere like saudi
arabia and lots of them are valid
but you don't see homeless people
right nobody's no no nobody's homeless
right because
there there's that sort of community
spirit and even based on the fact that
you know everyone is religious everyone
is
pretty much everybody you know 99.9 of
people are muslims so
they can't let their fellow saudi or
their fellow muslim or whatever
like be out there on the street so the
level of sort of
charitability not just in terms of like
financial giving directly but
that sort of community cohesion is
actually a lot
lot better over there so i think a lot
of what makes america
awesome is the rugged individualism and
is the
entrepreneurship and is all of that but
i think when people get
so atomized that they can kind of be
walking around and
see all of this you know i don't know
like people people just in total squalor
or addicted to
opioids or strung out on this or on that
and just kind of
get used to it and almost just you know
kind of just get to the point where it's
like oh yeah it's just
welcome to la you know that's just how
it is and i'm kind of like
wow that's that's weird and i don't know
i'm just i've only got one brain like i
don't know what this i don't know what
the solution
is there but i think it's something that
people sort of really need to sort of
think about and look at really deeply
and and look beyond the government
because it's easy to just say okay well
i pay my taxes i've done my thing um
i think i don't know what the answer is
but i think that people really need to
yeah i don't know think about that more
and think about what's
i don't know what's what's going on here
and why are we kind of letting this
happen because these people are on skid
row or in the tenderloin
you know these are these are fellow
americans some of them might even be
military veterans and stuff like that
and
yeah it's uh it's something that really
did strike me when i was out there
because
it was very visceral and i'm not a super
emotional person but i was just like
whoa
this is this is weird right i've i've
seen homelessness in every city i've
been to in the world
but not like this like this is another
this is a whole different dimension i
was seeing people smoking crack shooting
heroin i had never seen that before
just in public and i was like this is
not this is not normal this is not
acceptable
and yeah and i was even more alarmed by
the fact that people were sort of
seeing it happen and i felt like i was
the only one who was there kind of like
oh my gosh like look at what's going on
here and everyone else is just kind of
going
going around their business and i'm kind
of there like staring at the person
smoking crack like
whoa what's what's going on here and the
police are sort of parked up the street
just sort of chilling
um it's it's very strange yeah it's
uh first of all it has changed radically
and i also cannot look away and i feel
like
it is a measure of something that has
gone off the rails i mean there was
always a problem but it has gotten so
much worse and i feel like it is
almost a direct measure of a kind of
failure of compassion that has spread
that our system
you're right some of the strengths of
our system set us up for this
you know the rugged individualism and
the belief in competition
which have very positive outgrowths but
there are certain ways in which they
just set us up for failure
and i think you know the homeless
problem in some
weird way mirrors our failure on covet
19.
that rugged individualism caused us to
demonize each other over you know
what protests you were allowed to attend
and whether you thought
masks were tyranny or you thought you
know you should
wear them to bed or i don't know um
so that whole thing resulted in us just
simply not
managing covet 19 at all right we did a
terrible job
and i think your diagnosis is exactly
right there was
a feeling of camaraderie it was never
complete there was always suspicions and
a bit of prejudice but
we're we're losing the thread yeah right
yeah
and the commonalities are really
important because
you know and i i did hope i mean i did
i'll be honest when this when this sort
of pandemic started you know sort of
nationally and internationally i did
kind of
because i've been joking for a long time
and it's one of my half jokes that we
need a war
right i've been sort of saying that for
many years because it's like
a lot of the problems almost seem to be
problems of excess and people just kind
of being bored and being too comfortable
so they find all this other nonsense to
get obsessed with so i did kind of think
like oh wow
okay this could be the thing that makes
people you know like a common enemy
and then people are just like okay you
know let's let's drop the nonsense
and you know let's put the arms down and
stop the mudslinging
and let's just deal with this thing but
the opposite happened and it became very
politicized and
i'd imagine that a lot of people a lot
of extra people died who didn't need to
die
because of the politicization of this
issue whether that's
within the media or amongst certain
leaders or you know
this person doesn't want to work with
that person because they don't and i'm
just like look
stop being children like this is just
get
on with what needs to be done and of
course there's an election year so
everybody's going to be thinking
you know for example trump could want to
do something
that would actually like you know very
legitimately
help but his opposition both in the
media and
you know his democratic party opponents
might want to block it
not because despite the fact it's going
to actually help americans
but they think oh that might help him
get reelected right
and vice versa this runs in sort of both
directions
and i'm just like look as long as long
as people are thinking that way
then you've got like a big problem
because that's not i i'm very much one
of those people who's like
i don't know when it comes to you know
people can have their feelings about
trump or you know boris johnson or
whatever world leaders i'm one of those
people who's like
look i'm i want whoever is
i'm i'm an inverted comma supporter of
whoever is leading right like if you're
if you're in the cockpit of the plane i
want
i want the plane to fly smoothly i want
you to land the plane
well it doesn't matter if i personally
like the way you tweet or the way you
speak or not right like
cool you're you're in charge you've been
democratically elected
let's you know sure you know maybe maybe
the vote will go my way this time but
here we are so let's just kind of let
let's kind of get on with things and
that seems like less and less people
are willing to do that nobody wants to
seed
any ground or compromise at all
or anything and it's um
yeah i don't know i do i do hope it
improves and i'm generally an optimist
so i think it will but um
yeah i just think you know i think
people just need to be more mature about
stuff
you know like have this conversation
we're having now more people need to
have this conversation right if you uh
if your
i don't know your your mother or your
brother or your sister or your friend
voted for trump and you voted for
hillary like instead of blocking them on
facebook and deleting their phone number
like when you sit down and have a
conversation
and build some empathy and see where you
agree see where you disagree understand
people's mindsets etc and so you know
again looking over
looking over the pond it does i mean
we've had this in the uk because
you know there were lots of parallels
between the 2016 brexit election and
the trump thing and here in the uk you
had people saying things like everybody
who voted for brexit is racist
in the us you've still got people saying
that everybody who voted for trump is
racist
and and people like to do that because
it gets a lot of likes on social media
you know it gets a lot of retweets but
i'm just like this is not helpful
calling millions and millions and
millions of people
racist which is a really bad thing to
you know racism is is is bad racism is
evil it's not
calling someone a racist shouldn't just
be like a flippant comment
like that's that's a heavy charge so if
you're gonna call like i don't know
60 million americans you're gonna call
you know
dozens of millions of british people
racist
because of what box they ticked
then you can't do that and then complain
about
um division right you you can't
that's not coherent you have to be able
to
agree to disagree you have to be able to
empathize and say okay look i don't
you know someone can be totally opposed
to i know people who you know are really
really really
not fans of trump very very you know
they do not like him at all
but they can understand that not
everybody who voted for him is
a racist or a white supremacist or
whatever right some people
you know some people care more about
this issue some people care more at that
that about that
whatever and you know the same way the
other way around not everyone who voted
for
you know the democrats is wanting to you
know
have institute communism in the u.s or
to
and this is obvious and i i think
fundamentally i think most people know
this
i think most people know it but it just
gets so
it's get so jacked up i think social
media makes it worse i think traditional
media makes it worse
all of this makes it worse but when you
actually just sit down and talk to
people like human beings
then you realize oh okay you know maybe
we maybe we thought we were that far
apart
but actually it's you know we actually
overlap on a lot of things and
i've learned some things from this
person and maybe that you know i've
shared some views with them and then you
actually get the you get the whole
picture because everyone has their blind
spots
and you can't see your own blind spot so
unless you talk then you
you won't have the whole picture i i
agree you say
it's it's probably obvious i think it
should be but it really is
and um you know i like your
your point about the pilot i absolutely
feel this way and i remember you know i
would never have voted for trump
but the night he was elected i said to
heather
you know a he has the opportunity to be
the greatest president
in history if he decides now he's he's
done the thing that's hardest which is
to break through the duopoly and be
elected in spite of their desire that
you not be
right if he took the capital that he had
at that point
and directed it at you know pure
leadership he could have been
an absolute hero but yeah what you say
how could anybody not be rooting for the
leader to do well
and i do feel like those who voted
against trump were rooting for
him to fail in spite of the fact that
what he would be failing at is governing
their nation like it just doesn't it
doesn't add up that you would root
against him you could expect that he
would fail
but to root against him oh it's the the
height of insanity
and yet that is what the experience of
being an american in that period was
there were just a lot of people
um rooting for his failure
yeah it's and it's and it's a shame you
know it's a it's a shame because
i don't know maybe people are too
i think first i think a lot of people
are just too politically
jacked up right now i think politics has
become
it's it's got its tentacles in
everything now it's what i'm not a fan
of you know seeing it
seeping into sports and into music and
into video games and it's like
all i'm kind of like look i don't i know
ben and jerry's has always been a little
bit political but like i don't need my
i just want my ice cream you know i
don't
i don't i don't need all of the all of
this stuff with it you know i just want
to
get on with things and yeah i don't know
i think um
yeah it just it constantly and people
are very reactionary right so
it puts people it puts people on the
defensive and people start playing
the game against each other and
i i i there's something i say which is
that i don't
i'm not a fan of bringing weapons to the
fight that i wouldn't want being used
against me
so when people start there are certain
weapons i just don't think people should
bring to the party it's why it's a big
reason why i'm not a fan of identity
politics
because as soon as you start shouting
black power black lives matter only buy
from black businesses
black this black that whatever
eventually you will get a reactionary
movement
saying white power white lives matter
only buy from white business
and now you don't you know you you've
what do you say against that if if it's
perfectly fine and even good this one
way
then what is now your argument against
you know
people who are now saying this on the
other side of things
is this is this the weapon you want to
bring to the party
and i i think not and not everyone seems
to understand that i just think it's
very myopic i think it's very
short-sighted view
of the way to do things or even you know
higher up level higher up levels in
politics and um
you know i think something that you know
i'm i'm more sympathetic towards trump
than
a lot of people are but i think that
there's no question that he has
you know he he's jacked up the
temperature
many times where actually it would have
been good to bring down the temperature
a great example would be you know during
some aspects of this pandemic during
some of the you know when the
demonstrations are going on and the
riots and this
i thought actually he's had a great
potential opportunity to sort of step up
and take the wind out of the sails
of his opponents and the media and the
people who want to constantly
berate him you know stop giving them
ammo right don't don't go on and say
you know when the looting starts the
shooting starts like that's not
right it just jacks up the temperature
it makes people more
more divisive more hostile etc i think
okay look this is the time
and and that's probably one of his
strengths right one of his strengths is
that he fights fire with fire and people
love that
so if the media is talking crap he'll
come and he'll talk crap about the media
and people like that and people cheer
but sometimes you need to know when to
be like
okay let me swallow a bit of pride
and just calm things down a little bit
and i think by him doing that as a
leader
i do think to some degree it's probably
encouraged other
politicians and other people to sort of
play that same
game i mean if you you you spend time on
twitter
i mean when you see certain tweets i
mean you're like this isn't i'm looking
at certain tweets and i'm like this is
an elected official
this is a governor this is a mayor this
is a president this is
you're reading it there's a there's a
degree of it which can be funny
but at the same time you're kind of like
good grief this is something like
you know fourth graders would be sending
back and forth
to each other especially when they get
in arguments with each other and they
start you know
calling each other all kinds of names
and insults and
it's yeah it's um it's weird
it's i don't really know what to say
about it
well i mean it you know you keep hitting
the nail on the head the
thing the thing about trump that i
absolutely cannot stand
is that he cannot view any issue
in non-political terms and i consider it
absolutely unpatriotic
um which is a weird thing to say but um
but nonetheless it it's a tragic failure
on his part
unfortunately it's the downside to the
thing that did allow him
to break through the duopoly right yeah
he is a
brilliant political strategist and that
political strategist just
can't can't be silent so that he can
lead
so he doesn't lead he politicizes and
it's very dangerous and then to your
other point
the um emerging black identitarianism
is inevitably going to create white
identitarianism it actually
legitimizes it because if you're going
to divide us into those teams
then you can't very well expect people
not to play
on a team yeah so yeah if we're to avoid
that we have to
we have to shift out of this mode of
imagining that that's a solution because
it's going to result
i mean i really think it's going to tear
the us apart and
um as likely if biden is elected as if
trump remains in office
yeah yeah yeah i think people just there
are
certain games i think you win by just
not playing all right just don't play
just don't play that game don't get
dragged into this thing
it's something i experience right i
always feel like i've often got people
especially nowadays you know trying to
drag trying to drag me into things that
i'm just not
like i'm just like no i don't wanna i
don't wanna get in i don't wanna get
involved with this thing i don't think
it's a good
i don't think it's a good idea i don't
think it i don't think it helps like
my my worldview is really really simple
when it comes to stuff like this and it
is you know it is the martin luther king
jr
vision and you know the way i was raised
from from when i was a child
you know growing up in saudi arabia from
from the beginning i've been surrounded
by
all types of different people different
religions
different colors different ethnicities
different nationalities whatever that's
just been the norm for me
forever so the whole
idea of viewing people through this very
narrow lens
from a child i've always thought it's
silly and it's asinine and
it makes me somewhat upset when i sort
of just see that now like you know day
in and day out and it's
white this and black that and i'm just
like just can we can we
stop right like so much of this is just
it's just unnecessary and it's
antagonizing and
and it just forces people to keep
viewing
the world through that way when there
are just so many other like that's the
least interesting
thing it's such an uninteresting thing
about someone that's the thing
it's i i think the fact that i'm a black
male
is one of the least interesting things
about me it certainly doesn't say
anything about my my personality or my
character or my beliefs or my abilities
or anything
um it's yeah it's sure it's observable
and
cool okay that's it right but if you're
if someone is talking to me i don't want
that to be the thing that's
in their head and that they're obsessing
over i'd like no just talk to me i'm
zooby like just
just talk to me like we'll be cool we
can be friends like i don't
all that stuff is is details and um
yeah but it's hard i think that but i
think i think what is good
i think something that's good is that
there is this sort of
i think there is a growing tent of
people who are
i guess you know politically sort of in
the center left and center right
who are sort of uniting
and recognizing okay what what
these people all have in common is that
they're tired of the extremism
and they don't like cancel culture and
they don't like
you know this super identity politics
thing on any side
and they don't want to destroy the whole
system
and they don't think the country is
terrible and you know like
i think there's that there's that
growing group of people who i think are
slowly
gaining a bit more and more courage and
i think that they're sort of seeing
you know podcasts like this and what i'm
doing with my podcast and you know
whether it's
joe rogan or dave rubin etc like all
these guys they're sort of seeing okay
cool
people are talking about this and
there's a range of people here who are
sensible and don't want to scream at
each other
and call each other racist every three
seconds and just
you know there's there's that growing
group so i do hope that
that swells and gains enough sort of
courage and momentum
for people to eventually just be like
okay look like we're gonna just
we're gonna stop entertaining the
crazies
and we're gonna stop letting them sort
of determine everything
and set all the rules and control
everybody and cancel everybody
and i think once enough once there's
enough critical mass there
then i think you can get back to a sort
of stage of normal normalcy
where people are just sort of being like
reasonable again and we can actually
solve some of the problems because we
can talk
totally agree and i have a uh a weird
sense about this
which is
i hate to put in monetary terms but it's
almost like
everybody is hemorrhaging money and that
there's an easy way to stop but they
just don't realize it
and so i've been trying to advise people
get rid of your prejudice and your
bigotry because it's like giving
yourself a huge
raise right if you have prejudice and
bigotry and you're walking down the
street suspicious of people you're
paying a cost for this thing
if you get rid of that right what
happens is actually
the world becomes much more like the big
barbecue full of people that you don't
know
but you could sit down next to any one
of them and suddenly a conversation can
happen and
maybe you're not going to agree maybe
that's the best thing that can happen
because if you don't agree
you actually might discover something
whereas if you agree perfectly there's
nothing to learn
so for those of us who do this i think
there's a kind of a
very positive sense of camaraderie
even when people are across an
ideological line that it's not personal
and that the conversation will be
interesting
when we have it and the the hard part is
just
getting people to realize that they will
feel better
if they just try it out right if they
just give people the benefit of the
doubt
and they don't leap you know even if
somebody admits a prejudice and it's a
bad one
if you can figure out how to cross the
boundary and
correct them help them see what they
don't see that actually feels good too
so um you know give yourself a raise is
kind of the way i think
uh it needs to be packaged in order for
people to understand what we're saying
yeah i like that and a way i look at it
as well is that um
you know i've long been a believer that
i can learn something from everybody
right and that also every stranger is a
potential friend
so that's really something it's been
really helpful actually throughout my
music as well especially as an
independent artist that sort of approach
but part of the reason why that makes
sense is even from a
even from a a selfish perspective it's
stupid to be
prejudiced and discriminatory because
you're cutting off so many potential
people
who could help you or who
might be friends or who might be you
know and it's like why would you want to
limit yourself
so you know you're handicapping yourself
if you
only you know if i only spoke to other
christians
right and i only associated whether like
i'm cutting off
the majority of the world right if i
only associated with
other black people and i only bought
from black businesses and i only
it's like what am i doing right there's
there's all of these people here there's
all of these opportunities
and i'm so stuck in my thing with my
prejudices that i don't
that i can't engage in all of this other
stuff and it doesn't
it doesn't make sense and then of course
from you know from the moral perspective
you know we're all we're all humans you
know we're all
we're all uh you know related in many
ways and so
yeah just treat people decently you know
be kind to each other it's not
it's not that hard not only is it not
that hard but
once you get used to it you'll love it
yeah it's not an hour yeah
all right two more things before i let
you go um
so i should say like most of my uh
listeners i have certainly had the
occasional simultaneous fight with a
bear and a chimpanzee
right but your uh wikipedia page says
that you have fought a bear a chimpanzee
and a kangaroo simultaneously what's
that about
is that actually on my wikipedia page it
is on your wikipedia
i didn't even know i had a wikipedia
page until this podcast so um you should
check it out it says all kinds of
interesting things oh wow
all right i wasn't i wasn't aware of
that but um so that yeah this never
happened
um i meant now i now i wish i kind of
wish it had
but uh no not yet my guess is you're
probably just forgetting that it
happened
five minutes after we're done it's gonna
occur to you that that's a reference to
all right um last thing and it's a
two-part question
you said you've released five albums uh
five albums and three eps so
eight releases in total okay so i wanna
ask you two questions
for the person who is a rap
is it fair to say a rap hip-hop
aficionado or should i really be
separating those
no that's that's fine but hip-hop is the
culture rap is the music
okay good so for a rap aficionado
which of your albums or eps would you
direct people to the one you're proudest
of or you think they should encounter
first
i would recommend they listen to
perseverance perseverance
okay yeah perseverance now a different
question
for somebody like me who is aware that
if i had grown up with rap or had found
myself deeply involved in it i would
know
how to to wade into those waters but
having not
grown up with it it always seems a
little unmusical to me
um which of your which of your albums or
eps should i start with
i would actually say the same one same
one perseverance i would say the same
one yeah my latest single
is ok dude which is not on perseverance
but
prior to that um perseverance is my
latest release and
it's got brand new songs on there but it
also has a it's a bit of a best of album
so it also has um my best songs from
my previous albums so if someone wants
to listen to
my best songs to date essentially until
the new ones come along then i'd
recommend perseverance
cool and uh other artists that you think
might be
appropriate for somebody with no
background in rap
oh boy oh wow that's that's actually
tricky
that's actually tricky because it um i
can i can name some of my favorite
artists
okay but um you know um
eminem nas jay-z tec-9
tupac biggie um
those would be certainly a very strong
start but um
it depends on what someone it depends on
some what someone likes in terms of
content
and lyricism for me it's um
clever uh insightful lyrics
hmm yeah i would say
nas eminem tech9
jay-z not not so much his singles but
his like album tracks
um yeah there's a lot of there's a lot
of deep stuff there i think when it
comes to hip hop and rap
um a lot of the best songs in my opinion
in hip hop are not
the singles i think a lot of people you
know they hear
certain songs on the radio or in the
nightclubs because they've got a certain
the the the deeper more lyrical tracks
tend to be the ones that are sort of
let's
be honest it probably goes for most
genres of music right that's the sort of
the album tracks tend to be the ones
that
i i like more because they tend to be
deeper and more introspective and you
know really saying something rather than
trying to get that catchy radio
single and the catchy hook and you know
the beat that
people can dance to in the nightclub i
i'm i like with the more cerebral stuff
as well so
okay cool um all right well
this has been absolutely fascinating and
uh
i feel like you and i have seen the same
movie maybe from
slightly different seats in the theater
but uh i'm really encouraged by the
conversation and i hope we can pick it
up again
soon absolutely it's been an honor thank
you very much all right thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you